Je déteste Hatton tout le temps, j'ai l'impression
que tout le monde murmure que
j'ai peur que les gens découvrent
ce monstre parfois je veux juste être
normal
Leena tu es un miracle pourquoi voudrais-
tu être plus Je me souviens avoir lu
les cinq premières pages et  sachant que je
voulais le faire cet homme est un Dieu depuis
la première fois que j'ai rencontré Richard il avait
une vision très spécifique de ce matériau nous
avons été impressionnés par Richard dès
le début il a pris la magie de notre
monde si au sérieux j'ai dit à  Kimmy
c'est le gars avec des ologies le livre a
des idées merveilleuses et de grands
personnages dans une belle histoire le
scénario m'a donné envie de faire le film parce qu'il
était juste très bien développé les adolescents pour
lesquels nous écrivions voulaient entendre
non seulement  la voix d'un garçon mais ils voulaient que
la fille soit le surnaturel puissant
et que le garçon soit les
familles mortelles différentes, nous avons la nôtre
J'ai toujours aimé les histoires surnaturelles les
histoires fantastiques parce que je pense
qu'elles sont actu  allié une excellente façon de parler
de la réalité ce qui a d'abord attiré mon attention
était qu'il se déroulait dans un
monde gothique du sud c'est tellement beau mais aussi un
peu effrayant et tout ce qui va
avec montrez-vous également je sais que
vous êtes là-bas et cette idée  du
monde surnaturel caché sous cette
petite petite ville cela doit les faire
traverser toute la ville tout le pays
ce qui est surprenant c'est que personne n'est ce qu'ils
semblent être pourquoi ne nous en avez-vous pas
parlé un gardien doit être demandé
J'aime l'idée  c'était une histoire d'amour racontée
du point de vue d'un jeune homme
tombant amoureux d'une fille par opposition
à l'inverse Je pense que
ce qui rend la perspective masculine
différente, c'est que vous pouvez me voir la
courtiser et où  Je viens de vous
ne savez rien de moi,
c'était différent parce que c'est un gros
livre et quand vous vous adaptez, il y avait
certaines idées que je sentais que je ne pouvais pas
traduire en film et j'ai donc dû me concentrer
sur ce qui bougerait vraiment  l'histoire
dans un film et pour moi c'était l'
histoire d'amour entre maintenant et mon anniversaire Je
veux juste être avec vous tous les
personnages ils travaillent ensemble comme des
pièces de puzzle et font ce grand film il
m'a fallu un certain temps pour rationaliser les règles les
différents types  des roulettes et des pouvoirs
qu'il y a même s'il m'a
changé, il a été en mesure de
capturer le cœur non seulement de la ville
et de l'histoire, mais de chaque personnage et il a
trouvé des acteurs qui pourraient incarner ces
personnages Jeremy Irons était en fait
une idée de camis de faire  quand elle
écrivait le livre qu'il a apporté pour en faire
quelque chose auquel je n'avais même pas pensé
il était plus humain vous oblige à
contrôler vos émotions aimer ce garçon
vous met en danger terrible le scénario
et je pense que le film deviendra comme  une
extension de notre univers le niveau de
détail qui a été pris pour traduire
notre monde de la page à l'écran est
phénoménal nous marchons sur le plateau avec
Richard et c'était comme si
nous mettions notre arc à l'avant  encre nous avons presque commencé à pleurer
je veux dire que c'était tellement juste je sais que je ne suis pas
éteint elle est trop forte pour voir Alice
et Alden Jeremy Irons Viola Davis et
Emma Thompson dire des lignes du
script et le livre donne l'impression que le livre
est  vivant, mes pouvoirs seront réclamés
soit pour le lampadaire
tu vois la façon dont elle regarde l'os
il n'y a pas moyen de se mettre entre eux maintenant
ça a commencé
toi